peux et répète après moi
je kamala davey harris jure solennellement
je kamala davey harrison que je
soutiendrai et défendrai
la constitution des états-unis
soutiendra
et défendrai la constitution des
états-unis contre
tous les ennemis étrangers et nationaux contre
tous les ennemis
nés et nationaux qui  je porterai la vraie
foi
et allégeance au péché que je
porterai la vraie foi et allégeance au
même
que je prends cette obligation librement que
je prends cette obligation librement sans
aucune réserve mentale
ou objectif d'évasion sans aucune réserve mentale
ou objectif d'évasion que  je serai bien
et fidèlement déchargé que je remplirai
bien
et fidèlement les devoirs
du bureau dans lequel je suis sur le point d'entrer
les devoirs du
bureau dans lequel je suis sur le point d'entrer alors aidez-
moi dieu alors aidez-moi dieu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique  ]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]